this morning a hostage drama involving
christian missionaries kidnapped by a
violent gang in haiti is over the 12
remaining members of the u.s based group
have been released you can see them
boarding a plane here on the coast guard
plane in haiti at the main airport
yesterday returning to the u.s manuela
horcas is in miami manuel good morning
good morning christian aid ministries
the ohio-based group that organized that
trip said all 17 members of that
missionary group are now safe it is
unclear whether a ransom was paid but
this morning they're all on u.s soil
after that release in haiti yesterday a
convoy headed to the port-au-prince
airport it would be their first taste of
freedom in more than eight weeks the
group was kidnapped at gunpoint two
months ago by the 400 mawoso gang which
initially demanded a 17 million ransom
and threatened to kill the hostages 16
americans and one canadian five of those
hostages have been previously released
now those missionaries were reportedly
flown here to florida their conditions
their health at that at this point i
should say those details have not yet
been released but you'll remember the
youngest of those hostages was only
eight months old at the time of the
kidnapping gail
i do remember that thank you manuel